il y a dix huit ans que le général de
gaulle alors président du gouvernement
provisoire de la république créée par
ordonnance le commissariat à l énergie
atomique
je veux en ce jour anniversaire lui
rendre devant le pays
un public aux mains vous savez que la
france a toujours été à la pointe des
recherches concernant l'énergie atomique
ce n'est qu'à vous citer les noms
illustres de mes crèmes et d'écuries et
des 40
frédéric joliot curie avec son équipe
alban kowarsky francis perrin mettait au
point
l'utilisation de la réaction nucléaire
ces pionniers que vous venez de citer
monsieur le ministre henri becquerel par
exemple les voici
pierre et marie curie
frédéric joliot curie et sa femme
raoul dautry francis perrin pierre
guillaumat c'est au fort de châtillon
près de paris dans les premières années
qui suivirent la création du
commissariat que furent bâties les
premiers laboratoires d'exploitation et
c'est là que démarre à la première pile
atomique française zoé depuis 15 ans zoé
fourni au corps médical tout les
radioéléments artificiels exigé par les
thérapeutiques moderne mais depuis zoé
qui n'a pas cessé de fonctionner
d'autres constructions d'autres
techniques ont été conçus et achever
toujours près de paris à
fontenay-aux-roses triton pile piscine
d'une puissance thermique de 1200
kilowatts fournit son terrain d'étude au
spécialiste de la protection contre les
radiations
j'ai saclay cependant qui représente le
centre atomique le plus important de
france du moins au début de l'extension
des activités
commissariat à l'énergie atomique la
pile el3 eu l initiale aux lourdes
éléments servant à ralentir les neutrons
est précisément une pile à eau flux de
neutrons pour l'étude des matériaux qui
entrent dans la fabrication des futurs
réacteurs de puissance
un autre appareil prestigieux est
représentée par saturn ce synchrotron à
protons d'une puissance de 3 milliards
d'électronvolts prodigieuse outils
d'investigation au sein de la matière à
grenoble le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique a entrepris la construction
d'un nouveau centre d'études pour
décentraliser d'abord et ensuite pour
travailler en liaison avec l'université
et l'industrie régionale depuis 1956
l'extension et continue et mélusine et
tout récemment siloé sont des piles
piscine d'hôtel un maximum de
possibilités expérimental
le bâtiment de physique appliquée abrite
d'autres par des accélérateurs destiné à
l'étude des particules
toutes les études entreprises dans ces
centres porte aussi bien sur les
médicaments que les métaux qu'on
utilisera sur les satellites ou
véhicules interstellaire ou bien sur les
moyens de protéger les végétaux
c'est la chance de la france que de
s'étendre sur un territoire dont les
profondeurs recèle d'importantes
quantités de minerai d'uranium nul en
1945 les ressources de la métropole et
des états de la communauté madagascar et
gabon en particulier couvre les besoins
des programmes à court et moyen terme et
permettent une importante production
mondiale d'uranium et de thorium les
usines chimiques de concentration
produisent environ 1200 tonnes d'uranium
métal par an de nombreuses équipes de
prospection ont été lancés dans toutes
les directions en france et outre-mer et
les usines de l'ecarpière de gueugnon du
boucher de malvézy assure d'ores et déjà
les besoins du commissariat l'effort est
poursuivi pour les jours de plus en plus
proche d'accroissement des besoins à
partir des minerais français dont la
teneur est analogue à celle des minerais
étrangers on obtient des concentrés d'un
prix de revient compétitif sur les
marchés internationaux à marcoule dans
la basse vallée du rhône
le centre industriel est une pièce
maîtresse du plan de production de
plutonium
en effet grâce à l'adoption d'une
technique uranium naturel graphite gaz
comprimé ont produites ici non seulement
le précieux métal rare mais également et
en même temps 70 1000 kilowatts de
courant électrique
la pile g2 et sa jumelle g3 le symbole g
veut dire que les neutrons sont ralentis
par le graphite de 200 1000 kilowatts
chaleur chacune sont entrés en
divergence en 1958 et 1959
d'autre part parallèlement à la
production du plutonium g1 g2 et g3 on
fournit plus d'un milliard de
kilowattheures au réseau électrique
français
près de donzère mondragon à pierrelatte
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique
entrepris la construction d'une usine de
séparation isotopique de l'uranium 235
ce métal est nécessaire au
fonctionnement de certains types de
réacteurs
c'est l'uranium enrichi qu'il fournira
d'autres par l'énergie nécessaire à la
propulsion notamment des moteurs marins
on sait que le sous-marin atomique dont
le prototype est en construction à
cadarache quatrième centre nucléaire
français est placé sous la
responsabilité d'un comité mixte marine
nationale commissariat à l'énergie
atomique
dénommé comité directeur des navires à
propulsion nucléaire
dans ce même centre la pile rhapsody
dépasse tous les rêves des alchimistes
puisqu'elle produira plus de combustible
qu'elle n'en consommera
sur le plan de l'énergie immédiatement
consommables l'électricité de france
après avoir équipé les installations de
récupération d'énergie des réacteurs
plutôt ni chaîne de marcoule a mis sur
pied un programme de centrale nucléaire
comportant des réacteurs à uranium
naturel modérée au graphite est refroidi
par gaz carbonique compris mais c'est
dans la vallée de la loire près de
chinon que des f1 fournit déjà du
courant électrique au réseau edf 2 et
edf 3 d'une puissance de 175 1000
kilowatts chacune entreront
prochainement en service
le programme est dur est établi de façon
à ce que en 1975 la production
d'électricité nucléaire représente le
quart de la production totale on estime
qu'à cette époque le prix du
kilowattheure d'électricité nucléaire
sera sensiblement égal à celui du
kilowattheure d'électricité fournis par
les sources classiques ou venez de voir
les réalisations du commissariat et vous
avez compris qu il est un point sur
lequel son action était essentielle
celui de la défense nationale à cet
égard il faut vraiment que le pays
comprennent mais d'ailleurs il a compris
tant que le désarmement général ne sera
pas effective ne sera même pas malgré
les apparences amorcée entre les pays
qui possèdent l'armé atomique
et ceux qui ne l'ont pas il y aura non
seulement une différence de degré mais
une différence de nature et ceux qui
n'ont pas d'armes atomiques seront à la
merci de ceux qui la possèdent ils
seront à la merci d'une menace
d'invasion
ils seront la merci d'un chantage
politique graduée comme ceux que nous
avons vus avant la guerre de 39 c'est
pourquoi en préparant l'armement
atomique de la france le commissariat
apporte à notre pays et même à
l'ensemble de l'europe libre un élément
de sécurité et de tranquillité
indispensable car la guerre pourrait
venir d'une erreur d'appréciation de
l'adversaire éventuelles quant à la
volonté coopération de nos alliés avec
nous ce risque est écarté en raison de
l'action du commissariat ainsi vous le
voyez dans ces trois vocations
scientifiques industrielles et de
défense je crois qu'on peut dire que le
commissariat a rempli d'espérance qui
avait été mise en lui et grâce à lui
grâce à sa maturité technique
je crois que nous pouvons considérer
avec confiance les options que nous
aurons à prendre dans le monde
bouleversé par la révolution
scientifique d'aujourd'hui